[Musique]
derrière moi les appareils auxquels les
parisiens vont devoir s'habituer je
crois très rapidement les parcmètres que
les habitants de certains grands centres
de promesses de province connaissent
déjà bien les parcmètres ont commencé à
avaler la monnaie des parisiens le
stationnement et donc payant dans le
centre de paris un reportage réalisé ce
matin par eduardo depuis 9h ce matin le
centre de paris comme la plupart des
grandes villes de province et livré au
stationnement payant livré aux parcs m
il y en a à peu près 1000 déjà installés
mais beaucoup d'autres seront installés
d'ici à la fin du mois en principe le
stationnement payant sera appliquée aux
poudres et la terre délimité par les
rues de rivoli rudresh aux lieux et les
grands boulevards pour le tarif aucune
difficulté de 9h à 19h sauf dimanches et
jours fériés
une demi heure 50 centimes un franc pour
une heure trois francs pour deux heures
salle marc touati
moi je fais c'est un peu cher
je suis du quartier messieurs les
commerçants
vous avez trois heures ce point fort
utilisé ce genre d'appareil dans paris
oui enfin c'est la première fois qu'est
ce que vous pensez du prix
si c'est moins cher serait mieux quant
au contrôle aucune illusion possible il
sera très stricte des auxiliaires
féminines ont reçu une formation
spéciale en 2 mois pour vérifier que le
parcmètre et bien alimenté auxiliaires
féminine qui pour l'occasion ont droit
un uniforme spécial un uniforme bordeaux
c'est la première contravention de
mettet ce matin
mais ce que ça va coûter renvoyer vers
sa voiture
y'a plus qu'à
[Applaudissements]
il est 9 heures 10 vous le voyez aucune
chance de leur échapper
[Musique]